Aaron's next in Kansas City hi Aaron how
are you hey Dave I'm doing great
cool how can I help well so just to give
you a little background I'm on baby step
2 and I've caught a couple of a couple
of financial peace classes so so I think
I know what you're going to say but I'm
going to ask anyway so I we live in a
house we lived in for five years now and
as soon as we moved in we notice that
the house next door is not in great
shape and we've always wanted to you
know get rid of it or something
the people that live there they actually
own the two houses next to us so the one
immediately next door and then the one
immediately next door to that so it's
two different houses on two different
Lots not an acre and a half apiece and
they're cleaning up everything and I
caught them at the mailbox and they said
hey we're looking to sell and I said hey
well let us know when you're ready to do
that and maybe we can work something out
so they swung by our house yesterday and
they said that they'd be willing to sell
us both houses together for a price of
around $50,000 and they're worth
according to like the county appraisals
probably somewhere on the order of 110
for both of them so it's about half
price of what market value might be and
so I'm trying I'm trying to see if
there's any way that this makes any
sense at all at least from the
standpoint of being able to control what
the property immediately next to us
looks like and what happens with it now
so it becomes a rental property if you
own it
we're torn on that it could potentially
it probably requires some repairs we
could what we were kind of thinking is
we might go ahead and demo the one
closest to us and just add that onto our
property and then the one that's a
little bit you know the house down from
that maybe repair that one and then have
eight or sell it like flip it or or use
it as a rental and and have cash flow to
basically pay for the whole thing from
there if you flipped it what would it
bring I don't know I would guess
probably we can get depending on how
much we put into it maybe somewhere in
the 80 90 maybe 100k
so you might clear the lot yeah okay
that's tempting all right and you're
going to tell me you don't have $50,000
right of course not no no we're on baby
step two so we've got we've got the
thousand-dollar you know emergency fund
and you know all that good stuff I just
it kind of fell in our lap how handy are
you how handy are you on repairing
things I'm super handy
so I've done a lot of repairs are how
why are these people suddenly selling
this property you me I'll do yes they're
they've been they've had a lot of
struggle with illness and and we we ask
them what their goals were in the
transaction and they said really they
just want to be out quickly they have a
$33,000 mortgage on one of the homes the
other one they own free and clear and so
they basically just want to clear enough
to go out and buy a trailer and just be
done with it and move into a trailer oh
they know they know are they living in
one of these properties they live in
both of them yes kind of weird the
husband was in one of the wife lives in
the other so it's like
they come home and they hang out
together in the one house and then he'll
go over to his house next door so I
don't even though I don't even want to
know okay well I don't borrow money and
I don't recommend people borrow money
for investments and so I've got to
figure out how to do this without
borrowing money that's what I'm thinking
through yeah one way to do it other than
this weird living arrangement stuff
would be if you could if you could
option it from them for 30 days say
would you get would you let me tie it up
for 30 days at 50k and then see if you
can find an investor that will buy house
number two as is for 50k in which case
you cleared the one next door to you and
you never put you never took ownership
see if they can give you as if they'll
see if they'll give you a 30-day option
at 50k and say I got to talk to my
partner so if I can get my partner
involved and then you need to scratch
around find an investor that wants to
buy that other
and own it for 50k and then that'll
clear your lot which is really what
you're trying to do here this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind